[Applause]
how about the mother of the bride moment
she just got married to Jack antinoff
and um I always thought he was the
coolest guy so nice he's so nice they're
really good together he was in the band
Fun at the time okay and I don't even
know if he had gone into fun yet it was
this early he went into the band Fun and
then he became bleachers and then he's
Taylor Swift's writing partner they make
all their music together and now he's
lucky enough to be married to your
daughter they're a great couple they're
a really good couple
yeah it's like they're fun they're nice
good people they're very very very well
matched what was the wedding like how
did you feel watching your daughter walk
down the aisle of someone who as you
said is a good match approve of thank
gosh yeah yeah oh it was beautiful I'm I
just you know I feel very very lucky
that um she ended up with somebody that
it suits her she's very she's an
interesting character you know she
needed someone that could match her um
she's she's as she's brilliant
too Artic she very artistic so they're
they're a great match kindness is really
important because that sparkly stuff it
just goes away really fast are you
single I'm so single I'm so single yeah
but you need to date I don't wait why do
I need to date because I I know you're
young you're you know you you should do
it now cuz you get older and you care
less I hate to tell you I think I might
be there you're not there what if since
I started so young I mean think about it
we were partying together when I was 10
years old I'm going to turn 49 I am not
that I'm not that aggressive or
interested or I know what you mean I'm
very happy with my life I'm a little I
know what you mean well at the same time
I want to say I got really tired F
people finally gave up because everybody
would say so is there a man I was just
like you know years and years years go
by now nobody ask anymore so it's nice
that they don't ask anymore I don't
think anybody even but I do think that
you know we've had such evolution of who
we are as human beings I do think that
there is nothing wrong with being single
really it's I have great female friends
and I have some male friends that I like
too but do you think men and women can
be friends that's an interesting
question I think at a certain age you
can be you you don't think someone
really wants a little
more ah well I have to say most of my
friends are women okay yeah they are say
gay or gay yeah exactly all I love a gay
man all my male friends are gay I try
really hard to have as many gay men in
my life as I can cuz you feel there are
still men you know but you don't have to
worry about that compon there's none of
that sort of masculine whatever happens
though I did have someone kind of flirt
with me the other day and I was like
surprised I was like you know it was a
little Sparky Sparky Sparky and I was
like oh yeah that wasn't too bad you
know it's been a long time but it's
there's a different feeling you know
it's a feeling it's it's like they look
at you they say something and you're
like oh yeah yeah and you spark it back
you know what I mean I mean it's been so
long like how did you even know they
were flirting with you later I thought
about it I was like M because it you
know it charged me for a second in a
different way that gay guys won't do you
know no definitely not I'm like you
don't want me I don't want
you but this relationship's fantastic
and they nurture you they do a gay man
nurtures you which is what I love well
sex changes all the Dynamics I don't
know why but the second you have sex all
of the sudden expectations and feelings
and everything just changes it's like
it's a radical change I just don't want
to play role that's my hard thing